plus que 18 jours avant le premier tour
des présidentielles si vous ne pouvez
pas vous déplacer dans un bureau de vote
vous pouvez donner procuration pour cela
rien de plus simple le document CERFA
est disponible sur Internet vous devez
choisir une personne de confiance le
mandant celui qui votera pour vous doit
être inscrit dans la même commune une
fois le document rempli il faut alors se
rendre au commissariat à la gendarmerie
ou encore au tribunal d'instance avec
une pièce d'identité la procuration peut
être faite jusqu'à la veille du scrutin
un délai théorique pour des raisons
d'acheminement postaux il est préférable
de le prévoir plusieurs jours à l'avance
lors des élections présidentielles de
2012 un million et demi de personnes
avaient voté par procuration